خلف هذه الحركه النشطه الظاهريا في مدينه
كراتشي اكبر مدن باكستان مساحه
تتعطل قطاعات اقتصاديه شتى لا سيما النسيج
والملابس التي تعد من ابرز صادرات البلاد
لكن ثمه من يكافح للاستمرار في العمل ضمن
المتوفر من مدخلات الانتاج التي باتت عصيه
على شركات بسبب ازمه شحن النقد الاجنبي
نحتاج الى استيراد القطر وانواع من
المعدات والمواد الكيميائيه وحاليا تشكل
ازمه نقص الدولار في السوق معضله وبالتالي
لا يمكننا استيراد ما نحتاجه وبناء عليه
لا يمكننا اكمال انتاجنا لتصغيره
ويبدو جليا ان تاثير الازمه يمتد الى
قطاعات مرتبطه بالاحتياجات اليوميه
للمستهلكين مثل الدواجن اذ يخشى ان تتوقف
عن الانتاج اذا لم تتوفر مستلزماتها وعلى
راسها الاعلى
لم يصل الحال الى هذه الدرجه من السوء هنا
فجاه فمنذ اسابيع وحركه استيراد المواد
الخام الاساسيه وهي شريان الحياه لهذه
الاعمال متوقفه والسبب امتناع الحكومه عن
فتح اعتمادات مصرفيه للتجار
امتناع يهدف الى محاوله السيطره على
احتياطي النقد الاجنبي الاخذ في التدهور
بوتيره متسارعه والمحصله تكدس عشرات
الالاف من الحاويات في موانئ باكستانيه في
البلاد تستورد ما قيمته اكثر من 60 مليار
دولار سنويا قادر اركنتين هناك حاويات
مكدسه منذ اشهر في الموانئ الباكستانيه
ولا يمكن فتح اعتمادان بنكيه مؤمنه
لاصحابها لذا على الاقل تم اعفاؤهم من
رسوم الموانئ بالكامل بالرغم من ان ذلك لن
يشكل فرقا كبيرا
جلب حاويات بضائع جديده الى الموانئ دون
فتح اعتمادات بنكيه ودون نشاط تجاري سيكون
ايضا مشكله فالنقص الحالي في السوق بسبب
تكدس الحاويات والنقص المستقبلي سيحدث
بسبب منع استيراد المواد الاساسيه
وبالتالي يجب ايجاد توازن بين امرين
يامل المواطن الباكستاني كغيره من مواطني
الدول الناميه تحسين وضعه المعيشي مع وعود
حكوميه بالتخفيف من وطاه الازمه لكن
الدوله نفسها تعاني من تراكمي ديون خارجيه
تكبل يدها في وقت يسجل فيه الدين العام
مستوى قياسيا ككره ثلج تتدحرج يوما بعد
يوم
عبد الرحمن مطر الجزيره كراتشي